[Music]
foreign
just 60 miles from Washington DC is one
of America's most celebrated small towns
Harpers Ferry
situated between the beautiful Potomac
and Shenandoah Rivers is the town's Inn
my wife Ann and I bought the end for my
mom back in 2007. we want it to be a
good investment but we also bought more
with our hearts than our heads I think
as the type of woman who's happiest when
she's working so we figured this would
be a good place for her to work and
enjoy the seasonal life that she's in
I'm a grandmother so it's kind of
grandmother's house and I'm here mainly
because I've retired from teaching I
love historical properties and decided
that being an Innkeeper would be a fun
thing for the rest of my life
[Music]
the Townsend is probably kind of like a
circus Karen's the ringleader and you
never know what's gonna happen next
working for Karen is interesting it's
frustrating she's pretty set in her ways
and it's her way or the highway I think
what makes someone a good mom isn't
necessarily what makes someone a good
boss or a good business owner Karen as a
businesswoman she don't have no
experience and it's awful
Karen treats this place as both her
business and her home but more her home
I mean her bedroom was in her office you
know she sleep right there pretty much
in the dining room
I have asked Karen is this your home or
restaurant or is it an inn you can't
have it all three ways and expect to
make money Karen is absolutely a hoarder
Karen Hoards her clothes old shoes books
baskets don't even get me started on
those damn baskets there's baskets
everywhere you could open a closet and
hotel room and see a pile of baskets you
could walk in our server area open the
fridge and I bet there'd be a basket
there because they're literally
everywhere
Karen's in denial of what's wrong she
needs to separate herself from this
place or things aren't going to change
we are suffering we are in debt the
customers are going away
while we don't want to sell the Townsend
I think we're certainly at a Crossroads
of just saying is this becoming
overwhelming for my mom you know she's
not getting any younger and it's just it
could be a potential train wreck
[Music]
so if the ship is sinking then we want
to make sure we get our mom off a boat
before it sinks
[Music]
wild ghost place gorgeous
fresh food wow
nice to see you're in Townsend Karen
good to see you I'm glad you're here
gorgeous little town to remind you isn't
it kind of the queen of the movie sets I
mean it's just literally that many times
has it ready yeah wow okay I'm
interested to have a quick look around
and uh yeah I'll follow you okay
um what's all this out here what is that
oh that's just watering the plants yeah
and we get a lot of hikers and it rains
here sometimes what is that who knows
it's been here a long time just like
Freddy Krueger's hat who's is this it's
just there for anybody that wants to
borrow oh I see and does anyone borrow
that okay yeah interesting another one
as well and what are these things oh
they're for sale yeah see summary hats
whatever whatever you want to offer
we're very flexible I'm not too sure if
it's my style and uh almost done that's
a pretty special one um why is it so
special because it's full of dust yeah
West Virginia and this is Almost Heaven
how much does that one it's whatever you
offer are these second hand
no not bad some things are but not that
well it's your business are you selling
money are you are you busy no we don't
really sell a lot of hats I see well
have they got customers in already hello
this is my friend Sarah Sarah oh nice to
meet you good to see you join us for
lunch today are you I have no idea I'm
up to whatever I'm here I do uh what
does that mean she's just Family Fun
okay I'm so sorry right not a customer
is this a convenience store or this is a
dining room
wow I mean it's very claustrophobic you
know there's bits and Bobs of everything
those um freaky dolls they are sort of
uh souvenirs are you selling lots we do
wow but Dusty A lot of people who come
here have children they're looking for
something to take back this one had a
Collector's Choice how much is this one
I think 25.
dusting I didn't know they were for sale
you didn't know they're for sale
how much does this room make a month
um
I can't give you an exact figure because
record the purchases in with the
restaurant sales yeah that I would say
and 15 of sales 15
who drinks all this cider and no
actually we use that in the restaurant
geez well but we sell a lot of it it's
good in the summer June July and August
now my daughter made those all right
what are they they're little hats for
little children it's full of dust and
hair and what's this hot pads handmade
hot pads is that sixty dollars who buys
this people with children I hope people
with children
it's full of dust inside well you have
to wash it before you use it look
and what's this this is Sarah's Journal
so she keeps a journal yeah wow so it's
uh it's almost like a novel it is and
she puts sermon notes and telephone
numbers and prices and she calls it her
brain well public bathroom decorated
with baskets
she decorated the baskets up in my
washroom oh
damn okay wow so um all right what's
that there that is a bottle holder you
can put like a water bottle in it so it
does appeals
it looks like a job sock I hadn't
thought of that no you got a point
what's that down yeah that's our bread
and then behind that is the closet where
our potatoes are kept but uh are the
loaves for sale too
if someone asked for them and hikers do
sometime but normally it's um it's just
for the breakfast we have toast are you
expecting a lot of people that's how
much we go through in a few days believe
it or not really unfortunately they're
out of date as well we couldn't are you
serious second of November okay you're
right today's the sixth oh that's very
embarrassed yeah let's go to my uh my
room
what is that oh these are my famous
baskets yeah I love baskets and I
collect them beautiful baskets for sale
prices vary from one to thirty dollars
stop it thirty dollars
some of them are very unique you're
telling me that families come in here
let me go for a hike and they buy these
baskets on the way to the mountains stop
this one's full of bugs I guess I
wouldn't buy that one would you twelve
dollars
and that's with the Cockroaches we don't
charge extra
wow that was 12.99 it's reduced down to
five dollars oh bugs in there as well
bloody hell
so you get them as gifts and then we
sell them uh no I just buy them when I
find them places where the hell is that
it's an Easter basket Ah that's an
Easter basket [__] you know poor bunny
and how much is that one dollar yep well
can you go any lower nope huh we don't
deal in sets ah yeah yeah Karen you're
starting to scare me seriously you are a
basket case that's a good point honestly
there's dust everywhere up here as well
when was the last time this place was
dusted uh theoretically every day every
oh every day yeah this is my room named
it is
wow bloody hell
poor dear and this is it wow
uh wow we have five rooms this one is
130. oh oh [__]
what what
happened there you're taller than I am
see how it just lays up there on the on
top of the no see there you go the pole
is too short my darling look
so
look that's there
and this has been here since 2007 and
it's never fallen down are you ready
flip it now okay oh [__] okay let's
leave them there for now let's get some
light in here okay I'm gonna unpacking
yeah that's private what do you mean
it's private this is my bedroom uh well
but this is off limits it's got a lock
on it it's like a storage closet
but if I'm paying for the room I'd like
to get into my wardrobe you're not
paying for that you're paying for
everything else well then really we've
got these little things you can put your
suitcase on but what's in here my
clothes your clothes
seriously seriously it's very
inconvenient when there are people here
and I can't get to my clothes but I live
with it
um I want to hang my clothes in my
wardrobe 1840 we we use hooks
hooks
uh why don't you get me key to open this
I need to hang my uh my jackets
um yeah just have to use a hook
um once again this is a rental you're
renting me a room I'm here to help you
and I'd like to use my wardrobe
can I have a look inside then please
because I'm just worried in case you put
somebody in there
[Music]
there you go
literally all
that's it that's it well there's a few
jackets in the wardrobe upstairs so you
have another right above us is another
room and another room that you rent out
with a padlock on come on you're paying
130 for the owner's clothes to stay in
the wardrobe that's a first for me
congratulations I feel really
uncomfortable about having my Wardrobe
full of all your clothes
I can cover it up but it stays locked so
you can just ignore it can I just have
half of this then do you mind
oh okay
Shelley
Shirley
how much [__] can one get into the water
Gordon wanted you to bring some of those
clothes and things down just put them in
my office okay
oh hi oh my do you see Karen wearing
this stuff no can you remember it's
about two outfits what do you mean she
wears two outfits I've never seen her an
engine other than what she's wearing and
Denim and beige
comments from the Civil War had you ever
go through this stuff Karen do you ever
think wow I'll change color today maybe
a bright color with red or
personally seasonally so this is your
full look now this is this is how we
head into it in the summer it's usually
denim or a baby okay so no no white
after Labor Day then
never never
thank you thank you
wow this is crazy I mean I've never met
such a basket case like this in all my
life I mean the place is cluttered and
it's almost like her belongings are
everywhere you turn left to right
there's either a basket or an item of
Karen's clothing why is that
pillowcases what's in here looks like a
blanket more baskets of course my room
is cluttered and here look at that in
there
oh my God
look at all this stuff
okay
how could you fit all that in there that
is um
definitely took skill where is she
downstairs you're asking to come up with
you please this is insane Karen yes
Karen yes
look at all this stuff shoes handbags
scarves just smell them
it smells like my shoes
but they stink my darling they reek you
can't let me spell your shoes
they smell like um like my shoes yeah
they shouldn't be in my room well like I
said in my mind you rented everything
except this wardrobe which didn't tell
me that when you took my money you
didn't ask uh
and what about these those are extra
sets and linens yeah but why do I want
all them on these my bad and you don't
need to be under the bed do you
but we'll get this out for you and I'll
just put it downstairs
unbelievable
I just want to sleep in a room that's
not clustered
awesome
I have never experienced a place like
this before dolls hats baskets full of
bugs a Wardrobe full of the owner's
clothes to be honest I'm frightened
about the meal I'm about to eat
what's that
what is that yeah
can I buy this absolutely Chopsticks why
would you go hiking with a [__] pair
of Chopsticks and a little wooden spoon
I'll take that you can add it to my tab
Brenda I'm seating um Gordon yes ma'am
right here I'm going to start you with
an ice water okay okay
and Brenda's gonna be
once an hour at least any chance we can
go through the hotel
no I wouldn't think so no
[Music]
the town's Inn of Harper's Ferry Almost
Heaven selling on my room that's for
sure
um first name is Lamont good to see you
what'd you do a little bit of everything
big questions where'd you store your
clothes do I have any of your clothes in
my room no no sir no because we're the
same size oh no
all right
are you ready nice to see how long have
you been here two years two years how's
it going it's a little frustrating
sometimes in which way miss Karen is
just very chaotic she's eccentric wow
we have to knock on our door when we
come in and let her know we're here and
sometimes she'll slam the door in your
face or you never know what you're going
to get ready ready Gia I've never quite
come across an overdose right right so
out there and all this stuff outside is
that fridge outside that's our um
Kitchen products outside
yes and this fridge here that is for the
owner's stuff they keep their food in
there no look he's got to go look oh my
God stop let me move this
seriously
I'm scared
what's that what is that what is that I
have no idea
I don't know
parties if that's gnarly
so you have your own personal fridge as
well
yeah yeah outside well there's no room
inside yeah okay what's that over there
isn't it yeah this is where we store our
produce
this is for the restaurant yes seriously
look at that oh oh man I can show you
the receipts that we buy but I'm not
interested in the receipts fresh every
week where every season don't touch them
I don't want to touch it you don't want
to touch it but you want to serve it
Karen look it's disintegrated
more fridges down there
bloody how mad
how old are these freezers this one's
about three years old no when was last
time it was defrosted I don't know
bloody how
all this stuff stays outside yeah
Jesus a fridge so that's more like the
fridge
so it's a fridge
but there's more bread in here yeah
this is how much we need we keep running
out of stuff you do not need all this
absolutely possible yes the egg rolls
egg rolls
but you're just hoarding stuff Karen
do you smoke I don't know
me neither I tried when I was 17.
sausage brats
it's insane
you've never smoked cigarettes anything
else I've graduated from high school in
67 and that kind of marijuana but I took
one puff and it made me sick and I just
[Music]
all right
um you know I was hungry but I've sort
of uh rashed your appetite let's start
off with mac and cheese okay what else
the fiesta stew okay let's have a trout
as well a trout okay yes I'll get that
going right back
golf okay here's his ticket okay look
that's how he ordered it so mac and
cheese
are these yours yes well I bought them
can't open my store from your store okay
no wonderful I like it
so mac and cheese thank you ma'am
the mac and cheese that's mac and cheese
that's the mac and cheese why is it all
split on top it looks like a soup it was
in the fridge
and then they microwaved it
was scared to eat it
that is the weirdest and the most
plastic looking mac and cheese I've ever
seen in my entire life there's no
seasoning in there there's no salt now
please absolutely
mac and cheese he said it needs to be
put under the bed yeah there you go
thank you
now we're off to Fiesta stew Fiesta stew
so we have a Mexican themed stew correct
and when was the fiesta stew made I can
go ask please
hey Jill when was the is stew made
what's the date on it let me check
eleven one okay
[Music]
November 1st
today today's the sixth yes so nothing's
ever fresh never
terrible do you want some hot sauce no
no okay okay I'll move on to the next
course don't let me take that away okay
when was this uh caught
all right trout
and Jeff said he caught it yesterday so
he caught it from the frozen food
section correct
[Music]
how sad is that okay yeah
it's a disaster disaster all right
disaster trout it's disaster trout
what's wrong with it it's watery and he
knows it wasn't caught yesterday or
today
so what are you doing putting labels
um
magnet labels do not eat
no I'm putting ice cream you're putting
labels on a freezer to tell the Muppets
in the kitchen that that's ice cream in
that container Karen had asked me to do
it and when you work here Miss Sarah did
you get paid no I'm not on the period
all volunteer I visit a lot because I'm
semi-retired right now also this is my
mini bio wow blood drives I run blood
drives every two months right Wikipedia
editor I've done that
wow he writes art travel tutor ackermans
you teach Greek I do Inspire loyalty
you're a busy lady yes sir and then
um and then I run circles around naughty
problems and I run circles around
naughty problems yeah
yeah well if there's something that
needs to be figured out I try and figure
out a way to a way to solve this how
about a big circle around Karen I try to
do that I imagine it's a quick look at
the labels and any other any other
labels sure cheesecake just things
chicken breasts guacamole veggie burgers
tortillas and you just stick them on the
side of the freezer yes let me tell you
what you should be making a sign
that's the only thing should go on there
do not enter oh that's brutal
can you put that on a magnet and stick
that on each freezer and one on this
Karen's fridge as well thank you
[__] me
[Music]
the town's Inn is much worse than I
expected the owner not only has a
hauling problem with their clothes but
she's doing the same with her food
[Music]
um Le Mans yes sir why are you taking
these I actually wanted me to remove
these until she can I only took out one
bag at my wardrobe where's the resting
from oh I have no idea no I didn't know
she had clothes upstairs and she asked
me to move
seriously
come get it for me please sir holy [__]
I mean
he said he won't talk to you okay
yes
it came from another wardrobe another
wardrobe no no the one that you emptied
no I had one bag full of stuff no this
is the stuff that was in the black
wardrobe in your room
but where's this stuff going now to his
basement till I can sort it out
basements because I don't have any place
to store it here what is it it's not
close the things that came out of the
black wardrobe that we keep locked up in
the Potomac room
do you ever ask yourself if you have a
problem holding onto things have you
heard of the word hoarder
miss Karen this is your business
this is your hotel not your junk shop
can you get the team out from the
kitchen I'd like to have a quick word
for you all in the Terrace yes sir good
luck with that stuff yeah miss Karen we
meet the team and the Terrace one two
three four five six six bags you want to
check the things for bugs as well
[Music]
I'm in shock
are you joining us myself are you still
writing labels no I'm not reading label
no let's go
I arrive the facade on the outside looks
beautiful I walk through the door and
it's just like a cluster of [__]
crap everywhere moldy bread in a
reception freaky dolls up to the
bedrooms that's like just hideous
wardrobe's packed with clothes from 30
years ago and I had to ask Miss Karen to
get rid of the padlock so I can open up
the wardrobe and put my clothes in there
honestly the place is just ridden with
with this it's like a hoarders anonymous
obviously I needed a place to put my
clothes and so that was where I I put
them you can't just Hive in off a
wardrobe because it's full of your crap
like I said I've um it's just a story
Jerry no but it's not a storage area
just like your fridge downstairs this
place is played with junk on top of junk
freezes overbearing over full and that's
for the disgusting way that the fridge
is kept with a moldy salad there's salad
that's festered and it's like it's
almost sort of disintegrating the center
rotten
can I just quickly go on the size of the
menu there's two big kitchen's about as
big as my wardrobe it's two it's but why
are you telling me that when the owner's
standing next yeah I told her yeah but
we we have told her she won't listen
mac and cheese all separated every mouth
was full of grease because it was so
cooked in the microwave and that's the
way we do it people say that we we've
got the best food in town and the
friendship stop there
now you're sounding Slightly bizarre the
best food in town
okay well it depends on how you define
okay I'm okay Babe by my standard but
mac and cheese I mean come on
you know what are you looking for now
are you taking notes yeah you're taking
notes yeah you're making some good
points
thank you
and you're laughing
what's so funny then help me to
understand
I don't have anything to do with the
food
so I don't know what you're doing I've
got no idea what you're doing
would I ask you to basically so she does
what you say she helps me yeah
Chef is this correct I'll tell him to do
one thing is Sarah tell them Miss Sarah
tells you what she just and she said
she's a volunteer she tells my crew what
to do and it pissed me off I get I get
mad then he blame it on me she's got an
authority to do that I know Jeff you've
never talked to me about this
I have told you I have told you about
this
is
the way you treat the stuff nothing more
humiliating to the team that are on the
ground keeping this place open and then
a stranger comes in and tells them what
to do well she's not a stranger she's
been coming to them she is because she's
not exactly qualified to run this place
this is so screwed up this is bizarre
ain't nobody hearing me what I'm saying
and what kind of message you sending the
men you need to be down a menu like this
there must be 50 items on there
which 49 of them are turfed out of the
bloody freezer
so messed up
it's a mess a disgusting festering mess
are you anything nothing yet
unbelievable
I don't know I'm just so [__]
embarrassed
I know
[Music]
foreign
so far I've learned that not only does
Karen hoard items but she's also a
controlling owner tonight I want to see
how the towns Inn operates during the
evening how are you good and your name
is my name is Tyler Tyler what'd you do
um I'm a server okay great Tyler and
hello hi I'm Gage Gage what are you two
doing out here we are both servers come
in so I can talk to you where's the best
place to hang this I can hang it for you
sir I mean we're gonna have these filthy
hats I know why do we have filthy hats
in the hallway so it looks like a thrift
shop thrift shop how old are you guys I
am 17. I am also 17. objectively what's
wrong with this place well I think that
we're not well organized I also think
that we need to work on cleanliness
cleanliness yes wow is it that bad it
can be so what do you think is dirty
well uh honestly probably the kitchen
and uh
what what you asked what was dirty so I
mean common things that we try to clean
every day that we can't always keep an
eye on show me where the kitchen is
please yeah okay thank you
what happened here Sarah likes the paint
on the walls sometimes
what's this mess here this is a pain
for the wall is that hygienic you're
painting the walls of the kitchen I have
no idea yeah I know so why did you do it
Townsend became Sarah's Townsend even
though she had nothing to do with owning
The Establishment okay
did you see the mess in the kitchen
she's painted the wall
let me show you something here yeah yeah
yeah have you seen it yes it's one of my
favorite things it's one of your
favorite things no seriously
I'm live maybe not well did you see the
mural in the dining room that is a
children assist in guests That's Unique
isn't it what is that well it started as
a crack in the wall and I asked Sarah to
make a Vine it's not anywhere else
you've painted there is a uh in my room
you show me please
what have you done to my wall
this is so weird you paint over cracks I
look at this here I know and this
apparently is something new that is
falling apart
wow I mean it must be what what is
soaking wet the plaster's just whoa
these are bits of card that's correct it
was a temporary fix so it's not a mural
it's business cards you put your cards
on here and then you paint over the
cards
you should make a label for this
decaying wall do not paint over it I
mean
the Wall's rotten and you just go and
paint over it it was Amanda's a
temporary thing the wool is rotten
you're right and you just paint over it
you can't just go filling cracks with
tacky painting look at it down here
you've gone over cracks and holes look
Jesus
ah
ah what's that in there
um I put some sort of a mesh because it
was a hole and I didn't want anything to
come through it
I wish you wouldn't use that word what
hole what Jimmy is saying [__]
Hallelujah that'd be better
can you get me Karen I can get me Karen
please
Jesus what's your language sir
he's coming oh my goodness you know the
whole thing just started coming off the
wall needs repairing and she's just
painting over it and then secondly she
found a big hole here
started putting her cards on there and
then painted over that but inside the
hole oh Jesus
this is not a paper mache
what is she doing to your hotel it
didn't go outside I mean it's not a hole
to the outside it's not a hole in the
outside no what does that mean the stone
wall is out there it was sleeping on the
inside we're not sleeping on the outside
right so you're not going to get any
cold drafts or anything through there it
says just like I don't get to use the
Wardrobe but the holes on the inside not
on the outside and we can just do
whatever we want what's your stuffing
it's really salad
yeah we can't just paint over that well
you can we did but and then stick brillo
pads in a hole
you can't just Band-Aid this place oh my
good gosh just wash my hands you know
what a French bread as an app all right
um what is that the sports bar are these
TV screens one of those
microwaves how many microwaves have you
got well there's four here and one in
there that's five microwaves there's one
in there and Two Chefs Two Chefs
oh my God
that's the way to turn there's just junk
everywhere well this is cooking stuff
trust me I know what cooking stuff is
it's not good that's okay how does this
kitchen function give me a little tour
this is very challenging very very
challenging what's up man that's a
burger that I'm heating up yeah
you're boiling a burger I'm just heating
it back up when you say heating it back
up why aren't you cooking it from fresh
we make them ahead of time this is what
we got here we don't a boiled Burger
are you where the burgers are boiled
um no do you think a customer would want
a burger boiled in water they seem to
like them just taste the water
you won't taste it okay well I just
tastes like water with beef in it that
seems okay when they fix it up on a nice
kaiser roll with lettuce tomato onion
I need a Tom please [__]
no this is a joke this is terrible every
day I'm appalled to learn that the
town's Inn boils pre-cooked Burgers
Brenda well just show me the table of
the boat and what's more frustrating is
how Karen doesn't think there is
anything wrong with that come with me
two seconds I'm pretty sure something
perfect for me absolutely so that's your
burger
out of respect as a customer I'm not
gonna sit and watch it okay let me show
you
so this is the chef yes you just explain
how you cook that were you pre-cooking
it start from the top please I'm not
gonna let you eat that we um pre-cook
them you made the burger when
um
yesterday I believe yesterday just
explain how you reheated them for the
gentleman are we here them I put I put
water in there and I put the burger in
there
were you expecting a fresh burger or
some [__]
I will give you a fresh Burger my
apologies thank you I'm sorry sir okay
this ticket refused their food okay
young man
add respect for our gas take the ladies
outside and show whether we keep the
freezers yeah ladies and gentlemen just
bear with us for two minutes but yes
you're going to show you something I'd
like you to see yes so just follow me
this is just right down here
watch her out here yes
um right here next to the trash yes
um fish this is our lasagna
this is our trout
we got more sausage ice cream these are
your ankles right there
yes yes ma'am yes ma'am we've got two
freezers and everything's scattered very
cluttered I mean Karen has always uh
looked at this as her home obviously it
is embarrassing but it's a serious
situation that needs to be solved you
okay
so
my apologies though I discovered that
today and I added respect for you as
customers I can't sit here and fake you
eating that [__] so I'm hoping that you
can skip around the menu and order
something a little bit more
keeping my apologies thank you thank you
so much didn't you have purple glasses
earlier yeah yeah oh that is so cool
because they look like they're dark
brown or black
that is so cool this is insane yeah
Sarah claims to work at the Townsend
here's a free postcard for everybody
when I go to serve tables she randomly
show up we'll talk to tables um I've
seen her frustrate people so
someone calling me I have to go
yes sir they don't need to hear your
life story they want to sit and have a
romantic Dream On The Terrace
leave them alone okay in and out there
are other tables
okay we're gonna need a rotisserie
chicken
that's the rotisserie chicken you get it
from the freezer yep
disgusting
I'm just playing the rotisserie chicken
please show the table yeah this is the
dish of the day it's our rotisserie
chicken
it was roasted six months ago in a
grocery store and we're serving it for
12.
and you freeze them and you reheat them
in the microwave not in the microwave
put one in the microwave
what is going on here
well we have
a menu and we just do it I mean no it's
just pathetic how many of your guests
tonight think that their chicken's been
roasted in the house maybe half let's
just let me come in let's double check
ladies and gentlemen so sorry I'm going
to start your attention for 30 seconds
how many of you if you're going to order
the roast chicken this evening would
expect it to be fresh roasted in-house
could you raise your hands please
I think it's everybody
[Music]
a lot of people say it's it's good I
agree that it should be these guests
have come out of their homes to come and
eat what I'm not going to do is attempt
to pull the wool over their eyes because
they deserve to know what's going on
with those were cooked yesterday
reheating the pan boiling them in water
and I'm flabbergasted so you need to
take a real good look at yourself and
stop bullshitting customers immediately
otherwise I'm out of here I'm so sorry
but you as customers deserve better and
there's nothing to do with the TV
program I I promise you now it's based
on the bad practices that's going on in
that kitchen so my apologies but I'm not
going to allow you to eat
you're not gonna act responsible for it
I will
we're shutting it down
you just send everybody home stop
that
has possibly the worst thing I've seen
so far
how do you reheat that in the microwave
in the microwave
it doesn't even hit an oven but we used
to cook them fresh right
so what what changed I wasn't here yeah
so what happened stop I'm not serving on
it stop what happened hey it's Karen I
ain't the one that bought the chickens I
have a brother have a rotisserie thing
back here I can have Fried Chicken we
need new equipment this is what it's
resulted in this is what we're so you
can't buy this from a grocery store no
you can't sprinkle it pasta and expect
to call yourselves a restaurant I know
which is I know what you're saying
are you just like a butterfly fly around
just painting all little bits of [__]
over holes this is insane I'm done I'm
I'm upset I'm feeling sick and I've
never seen such a disgusting mess in all
my [__] life this embarrassment to
you you you and me
and I'm not gonna stand there and watch
you surf [__] like that and take
customers money what is this
I eat them often the rotisserie you eat
them often what does that say I guess
it's just that I don't
what does that mean to you you eat this
crap often
come on
you're running a hotel
the burgers were cooked yesterday
well when I ate them and I always tell
them they tasted good to me
where's the burgers that you cooked down
here sir get them my understanding you
see Pat in the mouth and then put them
in the oven how long for for about 15 20
minutes 15 20 minutes in an oven
I was expect burgers
cook like that
baked in the oven for 20 minutes so
there's no color on there cool down
stuck in a ziplocker bag out boiled in
water should we go and do another survey
what's 80 Chuck it's just your hamburger
you are seriously in denial Miss Sarah
would you like a bite no thank you why
not it's not cooked right well should I
boil it up for you get it warm
what color is that
White
that's what frustrates me we're all
pretending that this is good
I thought that's what the cooks I mean
come on no I mean I tried to blame it on
the cooks you can't blame it on me
because ain't nobody hearing me I'm
amazing not shut down
freezers lined up next to a dumpster
what lives outside in those passageways
next to dumpsters
bats rats and mice
you are in denial
you have a big problem
you've got no idea that this place is
crumbling
and you're just going through the
motions
Mr Ramsey my guess want to leave your
guests want to leave yes that's the best
thing I've heard all day can I [__]
join them
are we serving food at all tonight and
we're in danger of even being shut down
by the health authorities and there is
no [__] way I'm going to stand there
yes sir and watch this [__] been
reheated and served so sorry we're not
moving forward
you've got to tell me that this is a
good chicken I've eaten it like I said
yeah
can I go to the store and buy stuff and
resell it
can are you aware of what you're doing
do you actually care
yes
which part of this hotel do you care
every part is is how delusional you are
that this is a good chicken
what's in this one here stop that weed
cook yes yes what's that eggplant
so everything's just reheated the
microwave yes we're in danger I've been
shut down by the health authorities
I'm sorry folks
basically I take responsibility
I'm sorry I'm very ashamed and
I am fed up from not being heard
it doesn't matter what I say Karen is
going to do what you want to do
[Music]
what's going on
I don't have no help man I told her she
won't listen
for my best I can't I can only I can't
you can't you're gonna get [__]
arrested I won't get arrested put in
jail for killing some damn body I
Gordon this is the worst restaurant I
ever worked in in my life practices are
the problem right the sort of the way
that everyone's walking around in denial
they are but there's no standards though
you're not maintaining a level that they
deserve yeah I know that I know that
[__] so why have you become like a
zombie and following her emotions I'm
not I'm trying to figure have you given
up no I have not given up I have not
given up you're just as bad as she is if
you don't put your foot down and say no
I tell her no no no no no no no no no no
no and she keep on doing it
someone needs to draw a line I have
drawn a line
it doesn't matter
I can only do so much for it this is not
my place
and my apologies ladies and gentlemen
I'm so sorry sorry what a joke
have you seen any of this stuff going on
here do you have any idea what's going
on
what's this
pre-cooked bacon
from when
dated they they do it every day just
no they don't when was that cooked
that's not today if they did honestly
let's see what it says 10 31. we're in
November the 6th now this is insane look
at that in there
don't you drain that or
it just sits there in his blood
and in here that's all freezer
[Music]
hey Karen you've got no idea that this
is going on like this
what is that in there there's dishwater
no there's french fries in there fries
why is the water so dirty
nobody anything change it sorry nobody
didn't change it sir but you're cooking
fries from there tonight in that water
I saw them fill up the fryer twice
sucks
where'd you get the ham from
she bought it at the store holy crap
it's a spiral cut they cut it and put it
in here
and then use it for a side of hand for
breakfast
when was the last time this was clean
ah last year when I cleaned this Shelf
last year when we cleaned the oven we're
in November
last year yes sir
I asked Karen I said can we need to shut
down so we we gotta we gotta do
maintenance
why have you let it go like this
I didn't know that they were doing
things that were not parents no but
listen to me Jeff this that bullshitting
the guy okay let's tell the truth here
okay I asked for some new equipment
I can't get no new equipment why not
I've been here for four years I've been
asking for new equipment I can't work
with this [__] here and look
look at that
[__] pissed
I've been asking for this with new
equipment how long do you think this
shit's Gonna Last Ain't Gonna Last
Forever
I'm just so [__] fed up with every
damn thing
I can't get no help me and Jill pulled
you out of this and now I asked for some
help with some equipment that you can't
spend more but
look at this [__] look at this
tired of the damn line
I'm just so [__]
death with every damn thing look at this
[__] look at this
part of the damn line
you can't expect to work in this
are you greedy with the money I'm in
debt I'm barely breaking even
let's get real
they're out there wet Sands they're done
they're finished and they're a spin
Force
I've been cooking for 20 years and I
never had this problem we have to step
up
I mean look at the kitchen it's
atrocious look at this here would you
work in this I do
um so funny with you no it's not bad
enough look at the mess you can't do it
at all you own this place but I
delegated the restaurant to them and
then the bottom line is you have no idea
how to run a restaurant and all you do
now is blaming the stuff
they're taking the Heat and your
problems aren't their problems but they
become their problems because look at
the mess
well you don't even think there's a
problem that's what worries me
practices are so bad that's what I try
to say why has it got this bad you have
to take responsibility you're ignorant
oblivious and delusional
I'll do what I can do
I'm going tomorrow
oh man
thank God somebody else sees it but
other than this this is what we deal
with on every day it's nothing lost my
damn hat it's in there I'll find it I
know where you throw it you know we
could have done this without Ramsay
I mean anybody can no no
I don't have what do I spend on myself
now I'm doing the best I can I borrow
money and went out and bought more
refrigerators then oh we need freezers I
know I can't I know I don't why didn't
we just tone down the menu the menu is
what you all do you could have told me
that these are the things
I will tell you Jeff I have no stake in
that menu I thought that's what you and
Jill wanted no that's like yeah
you get your way you work hard I agree I
understand over the year you have
averaged 44 hours a week in your paper
manager
I don't care not maybe talking about
that yeah but that that's
I'm listening Jeff
you're not hearing me Karen
what a mess I mean one of the worst
dates of a kitchen hotel in I've ever
seen in my entire career also a owner
that is delusional and she's convinced
herself that the place is run properly
and you know I'm really uneasy about
just being in here
smell is appalling Everything feels
dirty and just and I'm not convinced
that even the bathrooms
are that clean and we're on a quick test
quick bacteria test there's a communal
bathroom that I am uncertain about when
this thing reads 30 it indicates that
it's a sort of
um a decent
level of hygiene basically is clean
anything over 30 then it gets into the
danger zone
that's where the smell is really bad in
here there's crap everywhere it's just
so unhygienic
and
whatever
clean to get a good reading grab the
swap underneath the mat a smell under
here is appalling in these crevices
this does
that's gross
that is gross
it's disgusting
snapping that liquid go down give that a
shake
then
holy crap
no
I'm Advanced at this place
clean every snails it's very difficult
for you to identify the smell but in
here it really stinks it's so
just it's just the smell from here the
stains everywhere and what scares me is
the fact that the kitchen took a year to
get cleaned
God knows what this too so pretty gross
and now pop that in there
I'm not sure when this place was clean
probably
then
oh my God Karen
counting here
turn
let's go upstairs please two seconds
please let's go quick
come in
[Music]
I've just done a swab test
with the carpet I told her the smell is
gross anything above 30 you're in the
danger zone for unhygienic practices and
it's not fit for customers what do you
think the reading is a hundred a
hundreds 50 50. 60 70. 70.
oops
803 oops Barney
103. wow this is just the carpet
can't be that bad we get a lot of bikers
bicyclist and hikers you're paying 130
dollars
to get out of bed and step on a
disgusting stinking carpet it smells
like there's crap all over the floor
probably because there's crap on the
floor probably could be
what does that mean could be
my first
shift here you were in the bathroom and
I think you had an accident on the floor
on the mat
why
oh my God I mean yeah there have been
times when I have had diarrhea but it
doesn't happen very often but
um no I didn't realize that there was
that problem
all day both of you have been in denial
not one of you told me about the
problems not one of you taken any formal
responsibility you are
serve that food to me lunchtime you're
happy to mows you around and piss around
on the walls and paint silly pictures
travesty this is shocking
your staff knows it but you two are
oblivious
but the rest of the room is dusted and
clean it is worse it's not he's not he's
not talking about the room it's not
about the rug it's not about the food
it's about the whole picture look at the
cage you're yelling am I not allowed to
yell Sarah because someone asked you
because you're not he's trying here to
help us stop being in denial it's not
about the rug and this perfectly dusted
thing that this is not going to make a
difference the whole picture the whole
thing
what are you scared of Karen admitting
well I'm working 16 hours a day and
spending every time these are rooms too
that I get positive feedback about oh my
God I'm serious a lot of pause there you
go again no you can't be that no no I
yeah one of those things I am not
sleeping
in this dump
I'm done
I'm out of here
oh man
you can't win I'm not staying in here
Ramsay
don't go
Karen this is a travesty that you're
paying 130 dollars
to get out of bed and step on a
disgusting stinking carpet you're in the
danger zone for unhygienic practices and
it's not fit for customers we get a lot
of bikers
bicyclists and hikers what are you
scared of Karen admitting well I'm
working 16 hours a day
Leisure rooms too that I get positive
feedback about oh my God I'm serious a
lot of pause there you go again no you
can't be that no no I you know one of
those things I am not sleeping
in this dump
I'm done I'm out of here oh man
he can't leave
Ramsay
don't go
I'm not staying in here
[Music]
is this your office in here that's my
living quarters in my office
I live there you live in here yeah
let me show you
what I saw the office sign on the door
but you live in here right here this is
my bed I just uh sleep here
are you kidding me
is there a mattress there no it's just
quilts cover on them cheeks
you sleep on a board
in the winter I could go upstairs but I
choose not to I choose to stay here I
wish bathrooms here isn't shower I use
the ones upstairs
what's the room next door oh that's the
beverage area and then beyond that's the
kitchen the beverage area
The Keg is right on the keger Raider
it's right on the other side there and
then that's the beverage cooler right
there
it's like I sort of sleep in the kitchen
crazy I love it here there's no place in
the world I would rather be you're not
doing one thing right
you have lost it completely and you've
convinced yourself in amongst the
chaotic mess that you live in that is
all right it's not it's absurd
this is no way for a lady to sleep and
live and eat you shouldn't be living in
a kitchen it's not even a fun or an
air-conditioned room it's a tiny cubby
hole Yeah cluttered with your junk
are you okay
I think so I mean this is not normal
what's normal and what's normal
seriously
I can't even start to think about
helping you
when you're in such denial
[Music]
foreign
the next morning I woke up not wanting
to give up on the town's ear seeing how
bad the kitchen was and learning that it
wasn't clean for over a year I hired a
professional cleaning crew
to not only declutter
but to scrub down the kitchen as well
[Music]
crap everywhere
good morning uh morning and about being
good so well it could be better it could
be worse yes so were you sleeping ah I
was I've got a headache
since I've arrived
I'm still unconvinced where I'm going
with you and this business however I
want you to do something all right
something you haven't done properly in a
long time
and take that yes
and start packing
ah
well no I'm not messing around I haven't
got time to mess around okay but we're
don't worry about that I just want you
to start packing up
quickly
I've got enough boxes
[Music]
yeah I do nine time is of the essence I
need to start packing and I'm I'm sorry
start packing quickly
I'm worried about Karen not listening to
me and I don't think she realizes just
how bad the business really is
I reached out to her son Jason the
majority owner of the Inn who has the
most to lose if Karen fails to turn it
around Jason how are you I'm doing well
thanks yourself yeah very well thank you
take a seat uh that's a what a beautiful
place yeah I mean it really is gorgeous
yeah I fall in love with this area uh
beyond belief um unfortunately I haven't
fallen in love with Ian
I'm shocked at the setup and what's
happening to your mum currently yeah do
you have any idea how bad it is I think
I have a sense but obviously I'm out
here on a daily regular basis so you
don't appreciate the in an ounce of it
she's in denial I'm trying to explain
things to her in a very calm way and
she's just
refusing point blank to understand the
Logics I think her her vision has been
both her blessing and her curse in the
sense of it's what's allowed her to
drive through this and persevere but
it's also what puts her in denial have
you seen where she sleeps
yeah
does that make you feel happy not at all
not at all I mean we bought this with
two main motivations to let her develop
this end business but also have it as
Grandma's house and it's not we went
into this looking at it as as obviously
we want it to be some type of investment
but we didn't have a particular game
plan Beyond just rent out the space to
Mom and we want to see it do well not
just to make money but so that you
really can have a life here and it's
just been triage since day one that's no
way to live no does this become a burden
on your family now or yes it has it's
because we're concerned for for her it
it's a financial burden this lady wasn't
your mother and she was renting from
your prophecy you'd be a lot more severe
in the way that place has been handled
we all bought this in part with with our
hearts and not just our heads and it's
it's that balance between wanting to
respect her desires to to make this
business what she wants it to be but
also realize that if it's not going to
be a profitable business and if there's
going to be a cost not just financially
but physically and emotionally we need
to we need to shut it down this is your
mum you know this is not a cousin or
niece or a nephew this is your mum so
um she needs to hear that
it's affecting you personally
financially you could drag your family
down you're not her safety net
I need you to have a word with her and
how we're not prepared to move forward
unless she's going to commit to change
and I'm talking long-term change
she needs help and she needs help
urgently
[Music]
after spending time this morning with
Karen's son we both agree in order for
the business to succeed he needs to
confront his mum that a major change
needs to happen well Karen um first of
all
um I spent this morning catching up with
Jason oh okay good and just trying to
get him up to speed with what I've been
discovering
you know I'm not happy and I think deep
down inside that you can't be happy
in this current existence
so
I want you to listen to Jason
as you know we've been talking a lot
about what's going on here why we're
here what we want with the business
you're my mom but you're also my my
tenant and so I have two main goals and
objectives with this place and uh one is
is a financial one uh for your sake for
my sake for our family's sake and then
my second objective is to encourage and
support you and your life you're not
just an Innkeeper you're my mom you're a
grandma and for us to enjoy all those
things we have to I think make some
changes here it's not sustainable
financially emotionally and and
physically
I just don't see the business in such a
Negative light as you do I I look at my
window you realize most people too yeah
I I look out my window and there's the
Potomac River in the train station you
can't see out the window my day oh I
can't I love it okay but even even the
bags of clothes yesterday are now the
boxes of clutter
people don't live like this
you have to get out of there and you
have to start living your life
completely different to what you've been
doing I'm not here for three months
Karen I'm here for a short time to give
you everything I've got to get this
place fixed and if you can't listen to
Jason and you're not prepared to listen
to me I'm not asking you we're all
working for the same goal here I am
listening I'm telling you it needs to
stop
for your sake for my sake for a family's
sake I can't keep renting the house up
to you if we can't get a business that
is consistently profitable the place is
in Jeopardy and there's not one element
functioning properly and your business
is going to take Jason's family down
if you don't sort this out
[Music]
um yeah I don't want to burden my
children at all
so that that is something that is high
priority for me
but you have to come to terms of
yourself that it's broken it's wrong and
you have to change and I'm willing
whatever you propose I'll try otherwise
it's game over let's move forward I'm
agreeing to help I'm going to put a plan
in place but
uh you can't continue the way you're
doing it you know that
thank you Jason thank you thank you
you know what he's playing
his plan I have an idea
[Music]
after Karen packed up her belongings I
had my team start the renovation process
while I found a place close by for Karen
to move into
hi Karen are you well
I'm very well thank you good let's step
inside something I'd like to uh all
right show you
come in please
it's got a lovely place do you like it I
do what'd you like about it
um well it's not cluttered it's not
cluttered is it yes I like that when I
saw waving living for the last
12 months I was appalled you shouldn't
be going to bed
on a piece of wood I know you shouldn't
be doing that if we're going to make a
change then you have to step back
and I mean step back from the business
and that means giving yourself some
space
so I've done something and I'm paying
for it out of my own pocket and I've
rented this space for you for the next
couple of months in two months two
months okay two months great give
yourself a break you can relax watch a
bit of TV I haven't had a television
since 1993.
so this is really a big change yeah so
since 1993. even if you're not gonna
watch TV read oh relax I'm just taking
the view and if you decide to move back
in there and you convert one of the
rooms and it's got an ensuite bathroom
that's all fair and well but then
you need to separate the difference not
in a box I like this I feel comfortable
here have a look upstairs there's a
beautiful bedroom there and a full-size
bed all right
there's a ensuite bathroom and nice a
wardrobe to yourself big bathroom
very nice
I could go to sleep right now
wake me up in two hours
we've got work to do
okay
[Music]
all right
that was comfortable
um Karen you need to you need to start
thinking about
being a boss being an owner with that
comes certain responsibilities what is
it like for you to be an owner what's
the importance
well the important thing was serving the
guest and trying to nurture a good
relationship with my employees right
that means setting an example yes yes
and being the face of the end yes right
what do you think is the most important
thing about being the face of a business
having a presence yes standing out like
an owner okay so you need to walk this
historic town looking like an Innkeeper
polished now I feel bad about asking a
lady to glamorize herself so I'm not
trying to be detrimental it's just I'm
gonna send you off
for a makeover okay when was the last
time you went and had a facial got your
hair done and bought a new dress with a
bright color
I don't think I've done that since I was
13 years old it was last time you went
for a blow dry
never I mean I
I never go to a salon right when's the
last time we had your nails done never
correct
and that was never a priority for me but
you're you're but we're gonna make it
yeah we're going to make it a priority
because it's about you
it's a business you have to front it and
that that comes with an image yeah
I'm glad you're up for change I want you
to feel better I want you to enjoy your
life I want you to appreciate what your
team can do for you and hopefully just
break them all a little bit 100 you're
happy with this um ready to enjoy it
thank you I have a security deposit here
so it's a rental no murals all right
we'll leave it the way we found it thank
you here shortly all the best team do
you want me to turn on TV for you not
yet
I'm gonna take this one step at a time
I've seen a few things on YouTube yeah
Instagram
never but my granddaughter is teaching
me selfie taking a picture of myself oh
never Tinder I don't even know what that
is
welcome to the Dark Ages enjoy
[Music]
just makeovers my team has ever taken on
we had not only moved Karen out of the
towns in but packed up all her clutter
before transforming the space good
morning how you feeling excited the sun
is shining and there seems to be a new
bright breath of fresh air on the town's
Inn we're missing somebody here we are
she's been busy over the last 24 hours
I'm hoping you notice a change
I don't even dress like this to go to
church
now somebody's looking like an owner of
an inn yes you look amazing for someone
with an Amish Mennonite lifestyle lovely
yeah I look radically different you look
amazing you look so different Karen you
look good really good are you ready to
go inside I've been dreaming of this
moment yeah follow me let's go
come on all of you
oh my God
it's beautiful what's missing
Karen's back
isn't this what a in should look like
yes a tiny little convenience store that
is bright and modern and everything is
on view and even if you're not staying
in the Inn Jess will come in and buy
stuff you can sell stuff properly it's a
proper little Boutique I'm over well
um it looks amazing amazing what Gordon
has done is phenomenal the store here
looks great it's like walking into a
whole nother place please
please
[Music]
what beautiful design beautiful well I
walk to this dining room first off it
was dreary and Laden with junk and now
we have a proper dining room yes
oh lovely look at that all day menu the
menu hangs on the wall is written daily
according to what you've got available
Jeff yes and when we run out we run out
we tear it off and we start again if you
turn around you'll see the custom
artwork on the wall please do not paint
over that I will not I will promise
I love it that's the only mural we need
on the wall just that enough is enough
yeah right you ready to see upstairs
yeah
as you come up have a little look at the
hallway first please
anyone wants to do a little bit of work
a little bit of writing absolutely
beautiful wow jump in everything
that's right
I'm like the same room
new sheets new bedding and a new carpet
it's beautiful
it's a nice stunning wall I love it no
more brillo pads in the wall they're
gone I love it
have your very own wardrobe
wardrobe it is exquisite my family
thinks I'm so set in my ways that I'm
not going to like any of these changes
and I'm going to go right back to the
old way I know that's what they're
thinking and they couldn't be further
from the truth
[Music]
you know spent the last two days
cleaning out the kitchen by getting rid
of the microwaves refrigerators and
freezers
I've created a much smaller menu that is
manageable for the kitchen staff to
execute please take a menu and pass them
on
could it be more beautiful of heaving
isn't it now let's be real the kitchen
is Tiny so a small Dynamic menu as the
seasons change and we go through to
Spring and some of them will increase on
a daily special only according to what
business is about
and so we're not buying unnecessary and
we're not adding 10 more appetizers and
entrees on there just because we want to
look busy no keep it plain and simple
keep it plain delicious and simple let's
go through the dishes a High Street
Burger no water no water uh beautiful
Pate wonderfully season a griddle in
there to sear and cook them to order
chicken pot pie
little modern Twist on a salad nicoise
but we've done it with salmon homemade
granola seasonal berries cheap as easy
to put out that tiny kitchen and then of
course the mac and cheese it does not go
in the microwave what's that absolutely
the sports bar of microwaves has gone
and Visually what do you think it's
beautiful and fast and it takes a big
load off in the kitchen yes and we're
not buying Frozen it's all fresh right
knife and fall and have a little taste
oh man that is good oh my that's like
Mama's macaroni and cheese people will
drive from Washington DC to come here
and eat this way
tonight the town's Inn relaunches the
inn and the restaurants right how are
you feeling
absolutely tough week but it's Been
instrumental let's put this place back
on the map okay push the freshness of
the menu I don't want anyone panicking
there's nothing we can't do on the menu
any issues we talk about it if we talk
to each other we prevent mistakes
happening if we shut down things will
happen without us knowing Karen anything
you'd like to say to the team thank you
and I'm looking forward to moving
forward there you go good luck let's go
guys
foreign
checking in it looks like immediately
the guests see the changes in the dining
room and the rooms yeah it's beautiful
yeah wow look at this very nice I love
this bed this is pretty nice oh look at
this you get a nice armoire and throw
our stuff in here how do you like the
changes looks good
I can definitely say this is way better
way better this is definitely an
improvement yes indeed
that's a burger with french fries BLT
and a mac and cheese right the kitchen
is functioning more efficiently with a
smaller menu and is preparing the dishes
cook to order and Karen has overseen the
Inn as an owner and successfully
treating this place like a business for
the first time that's everything so far
I heard you like this
and please yes I got five minutes on the
burger shop and we got two orders of
fries nice and crispy the fries and
seasoned beautifully yes yes Sarah Chef
well done
what does it mean a small little local
bistro to the town how good is that for
you actually it's huge uh we need more
local bistros like this we're really
excited to have it
take care good night
happy customers wow
[Music]
I'm off
thank you man you're welcome don't lose
that passion yeah continue enhancing
this kitchen and stick together yes
you're strong together you too yeah okay
all right see you soon look after each
other we will okay
tonight proved this place can work the
potential is incredible the locals are
dying to see this place at the Forefront
of this amazing town the area is
historic make sure you're in follows
down that line Karen I know change is
going to be hard I know you're going to
resist
afford to go back
I know how much this
and I know what kind of Jeopardy is at
stake if it doesn't work so think other
consequences it's not just you it's your
son your son's family and the Legacy
that you want to continue with so I'm
leaving you all the tools push
promise me you're not gonna go back to
your old ways no no
more effective and I just seen the
positive response from everybody you did
the the groundwork here thank you thank
you you have an amazing year yeah okay
amazing location beautiful you will not
move those clothes back in from a
Lamont's basement get rid of this stuff
let it fly off the shelves and start
getting this place back on the map and
enjoy that lovely little cottage take
time out and spend time with the
grandkids and just let the business
breathe
I promise yes okay
all right Gordon's visit has been
extremely educational this is good this
is right this is what it should be thank
you
I want the end to be successful and I
think it will be now take care now
thanks Carol good night
wow that's it that's it
all right come back come back
thank you
since my visit Karen has continued to
lease the house I had previously rented
for her and has been listening to her
staff to make positive changes that is
awesome and her son Jason has gotten
involved with the business to help Karen
meet their goals and both are happy to
report business is heading in the right
direction
[Music]
foreign